for viewers who've not come into contact
with parkinson's either through friends
family or even themselves
to just take us back to the point at
which you yourself
received your diagnosis
it wasn't a great day that's for sure it
was 10 years ago that i had my diagnosis
and
after walking out of the doctor's office
it was a
feeling that mixed up with being sad
feeling sorry for myself being angry at
the situation
what do we do now and uh and happily
that
we've been led along the way by well uk
parkinson's uk who
have done a great job not just for me
but for other people who are
always awake on their their lines to
give you any advice
to show you where the best sort of
places to meet people that have this
uh disease and so they've been pretty
good and the president of the uh
charity is none other than jane asher
who has been talking about us being
tantalizingly close
for some time now and uh this really
does feel like the real thing this
there's something about
this everybody's obviously thinking
about health these days they're called
19 but uh this is something else i mean
without the uh
the funding now and because of the dent
in the uh money that's coming into
of course other other uh charities and
covis is one of them
but uh we'll we need to we'll need to
find something like two billion pounds
to be uh
to be able to to carry on and work in
the way that we want to work and
now with it being so close it's very
exciting not time to open the champion
courts yet maybe
but soon yeah indeed but just on that is
that
the evidence of that protein affecting
the nerve cell affecting the nerve cells
now
it does appear we're at the start of the
process and no one is
known as you say is popping the
champagne corks yet but if this process
is followed it feels like even if we
can't quite get to a cure
in the not too distant future we could
certainly find some way
of perhaps limiting the spread of what
as we heard in ivor's report is the
fastest growing
uh degenerative neurological condition
in the world
yeah in britain alone there are about
145 000 people
affected by parkinson's and over the
last couple of years the
the team that i was talking about at
parkinson's uk have been working on ways
to
be make the public better aware of the
sort of work that they do
and uh and help in the uh you know by
working together like
uh jazz fm is going to be working in
tandem
to help us do just that and that's
something i'm looking forward to on jazz
fm very much
uh but uh i'm looking at glass from the
past there um
and um it's couldn't resist
but it's uh it's yeah it's all all those
all the signs are good
one of the other difficulty with this
particular disease is there are
oh over 40 different symptoms going from
hallucinations to depression to tremors
to
when you take your pick it'll be in
there somewhere so it's been very
difficult painstakingly
difficult for the scientists to uh to
keep up with uh with
all the developments and in this case
they've they've done it themselves in
this era where
science or scientists have become the
new beatles yeah
um of course the the things that you're
describing so often lead to a late
diagnosis with parkinson's or perhaps
not identifying parkinson's
quite as early but i i just want to talk
about you
the reason part of the reason we were
showing those old photos of you is that
the voice
david has not changed in iota and the
hair frankly is still looking
pretty decent as well but but clearly
clearly there are there are obvious
physical consequences of parkinson's and
i know from
personal family experience myself and i
recognize them straight away
how has that if it has in any way
affected your ability to work
well i'm really lucky um because a lot
of people in the radio industry have
given me lots of opportunities to to
work
others of course naturally or a little
bit wary of uh you know what's going to
happen what's he going to do and that's
that's why this awareness campaign
that they've been embarked on is so
important because uh you know people
you can't really identify one symptom
from another or if you fall down in the
street it may not necessarily be one
thing but it could be the parkinson
thing you don't know but people
if the more aware they are of it the
more that people will be able to
diagnose
and in this case this is a bit like
going back to the future uh going back
all those years to
identifying the protein that's so key in
this new research
and then um and then using that
information to bring us up to date and
look beyond
how it can be harnessed the big question
and all the parkinson's people that will
be listening to this right now
will want to know when that's the big
thing and i don't think we know that yet
but we're you know
that's what we have had false stones
before but i think this one feels
feels like the real thing as i said